ご視聴ありがとうございました
チョコレートを入れます。
チョコレートを作ることができます。
それではただいまより市長臨時会見を始めたいと思います
市長よろしくお願いいたします
神戸市内で月縄グマの存在が初めて明確に確認されましたので
現在の対応状況、これまでの対応、今後の交通につきましてご説明を申し上げます
すでに資料を昨日の段階に発表しているところですけれども
昨日、6月11日16時57分に、豪雨市近くの道場町の山林で、月のアグマが確認されました。
これはですね、これは、例えばカメラについて説明いたしますけれども、
有害恐竜の捕獲のために設置しているこのセンサーカメラのすぐそばでですね、この正銃とみられるクマの写真が撮影をされたということです。
この状況につきましては、プレスビビスをさせていただくときに、周辺の住民にも注意喚起をしています。
近隣の小中学校5校であります。北神戸中学校、道場小学校、神戸大小学校、長尾小学校、それから道場幼稚園がありますけれども、現在のところ臨時休校などの措置は実施をしておりません。
当然の大人が妻が出没をしたという情報については、学校などを通りまして、また独自にプレスリリースを保護者向けに配布し、医療法を共有しております。
神戸市が取ってきた対応ですけれども、神戸市はですね、山の中に感知カメラを多数設置するということを行ってきました。
2018年からセンサーカメラによる感知カメラを設置して、感知を行ってきたということですね。
その大きな理由は、日本以下対策です。
いずれにご説明したかもしれませんが、この六甲山にとにかく日本ジカを入れないと、日本ジカは北の方からずっと生息域を拡大しています。
もしも六甲山に日本ジカが侵入をする、これが繁殖をするということになる、取り返しがつかないことになる、おそらく永久に駆除できないというのがそういうものが可能になっています。
日本地下が多数繁殖することによって 全国的に多くの地域で深刻な被害が発生しています
例えば日本地下は特定の植物を食べるということに 外はラチカをすると
そのラチカがどんどん広がっていって いつかの地域ではそれが崖崩れや土砂の崩壊
大雨が降るとそれが土石流になって流れる
災害の原因にもなっている地域があります
それから日本地下は山見るなどを売買するということで
都談客配下など観光面でもこれが関係とすると影響が出ると
生態系に影響を与えるし観光面でも影響があるということで
神戸市はとにかく六方線に日本人化は見れないと
そういう方針の下にセンサーカメラを設置しています
2018年からスタートをいたしまして
順次増やしてきたわけです
そういう中でこの日本人化対策のカメラが
月の悪魔の監視にも有効であるという認識は
当初から持っております
そういう中で神戸の市の近辺で
月の輪群の各県が何県か来ています
これが赤で示したエリアですね
三田市が3県
それから宝塚市内が1県ということで
いずれもここは神戸市の市境ですけれども
神戸市なかいからそんなに距離がないところで発見をされた
宝塚市は2024年の5月
三田市内では2024年、2025年
県立有馬富士公園のパークセンター
あるいは鴨の福井園
あるいは鴨の第三公園
こういうところで発見をされたんです
そこでこういうような発見を受けまして
神戸市では監視カメラを大幅に増設することとお伝えしました
2024年度に100台のセンサーカメラを引かして設置をするということとしたわけです
このカメラは大部分がAIシステムを搭載したかなり精度が高いものです
AIカメラによりまして、この映った動物が月のワグマなのか、鹿なのか、タヌキなのか、アライグマなのかということがわかる、そういうカメラです。
このカメラはですね、このエリア、今回月のワグマが撮影された3台、魚塚近鉄、ここ90台、それから同城地区に19台、
ここは西宮地区ですけれども、これは神戸市の負担で設置をして20台、それから御社宝都地区が20台、それから六甲山県に近い谷上六甲山地区が40台、
これからスズラン街の少し北西になるんですが
アイナー地区が19台
産経としては老舗産経から離れていますが
丹生産の地区に15台
それから二期産田の近接地域に10台
アイナー地区に19台
ヒオドリゴエ地区に14台設置をしています
このうちアイナー地区とヒオドリゴエ地区は
まだAIが搭載されていないので
これはできるだけ早くAIを搭載をしたカメラに切り替えできたというふうに考えています
もう一つはこの有害鳥獣捕獲用カメラという別の種類のカメラ
これを50台設計をしておりまして
これが紫色で確保されたところに有害鳥獣のカメラを設計をしているわけです
このカメラの中の1台が
この有害鳥獣用のカメラの方でですね
今回月のマグマが確認できたということです
ここのエリアを少し拡大をしてみますと
ここが今先ほど示したエリアで
ここではAI搭載をした監視用カメラだと
ここには109台あります
さらに有害鳥獣用監視カメラが3台あるんですけど
今回たまたまですね
この3台のうちの1台に
この月のワグマが確認をされたということです
このAIが搭載されたカメラについてはですね
これはリアルタイムで確認ができますから
歯科が確認できたとか
あるいは月のワグマが確認できたということになれば
それが関係部署の方に通知をされるということになるわけです
今回の月の和泡の発見を受けまして
先ほど申し上げましたように
当然のことながら周知をする
万全の注意を払って外出をしていただきたいということを呼びかけるということを
当然するわけですけれども
併せてやはりカメラの監視だけではなくて
現地調査も行っております
神戸市は兵庫県の県立動物研究センターから
様々な知見をいただいております
また神戸市は長寿担当の担当課長といわゆる職員がいるわけですけれども
昨年の11月には有害長寿にずっと携わってきた
民間人材を神戸市の長寿対策専門員として
任意をすることといたしました
このような職員も現地
彼がその職員ですけれども
現地に行って現場を確認をする
その状況などを見ながら
例えば熊野足跡とか
クマが行動をした痕跡がないかと
実際に現地にこの職員や地下あるいはクマ対策に携わっている
現地の皆さんと一緒に対応するというふうにしているところです
やはりクマを捕獲するということが重要で
捕獲罠専用のドラムカムの檻ですよね
これを設置するためには
これはUI常住捕獲の許可があります
現在15件に申請をしておりまして
15件の許可が檻次第に
このドラムカムの檻を設置するという対応をしていくと考えております
今後の対応ですけれども
先ほどちょっと連覧地図をセンサーの地図をご覧いただきますと
かなりですねカバーできているわけですけれども
もう少しこのAIカメラについては
これは同設する必要があるのではないかというふうに考えております
特にですね心配なのは
観光地としては有馬温泉がそんなにほど遠くないところにいないです
有馬温泉に突然ツキノワグマが他の地域にもありますように
出現するということは非常にこれは大混乱をなりつくことになりますから
一応有馬温泉の近辺にこういうふうに監視カメラを置いておりますけれども
これは今温泉の近辺にもう少し増やすことができないか
他のエリアについてもですね
専門家の意見
兵庫県の野生動物研究センターの意見を聞きながら
増設を検討するというふうになっています
それでこのスキノアグマについてはですね
神戸市としては
これは公務室に出現することがあり得るという考え方で
先ほど申し上げましたように
鹿の想定した監視カメラを漏設をする
あるいはフォーラムを開いて市民の皆さんに啓発をすると
注意を呼びかける
神戸で月のワグマが現れたということで
これは神戸で何で土のマグマというようなことにならないように
これ想定をされていたというような事態であるということを
市民の皆さんにも良い理解をしてもらうような
そういう理解を求めるということも多く思っていたいと思っています
熊戸遭遇したときにどうするのかとか
あるいは福岡を呼び寄せないためにどうするのかという
これはもう全国共通の話であると思います
これは北海道、木熊と月の輪熊に対する対応というのは違ったかもしれませんけれども、月の輪熊が東北、北陸、まだ最近は東京近辺にも月の輪熊が出没をしていて、これは市街地の八王子屋、秋島にも出没をしているということで、
これは全国共通の対応であるかと思いますけれども
こういうような呼びかけを市民に対してより積極的に行っていきたいというふうに思っておりますので
報道機関の皆様方に向かいましてもご協力をよろしくお願い申し上げたいと思います
私からは以上です
それではただいま発表した内容についてご質問をお受けしたいと思います
ご質問の際は報道機関名とお名前をお願いいたします
それではどの方がございますでしょうか
神戸新聞社の篠原と申します
それはAIカメラの件なんですけれども
これは温泉周辺以外でもう少しどの辺りに設置するとか
対すると大まかな数字もあればお知りいただきたいと思います
まだ大きな数字はないと思いますけれども、アリマ温泉近辺以外にはどんなところが考えられますか、今まで。
これはまだ決定事項であります。想定されることです。
どうぞ。
環境部部、自然環境課の岡田と申します。
市長のおっしゃったとおり、今からまだ専門家として検討していく段階ではあるんですけれども、
やはり熊という点でおいてやはり三田高塚近接地区がですね
やはり侵入の経路になっていると考えられますので
やはりこの辺りで数をもう少し増やす必要があるのかなと考えております
基本的には熊はなので三田高塚のいわゆる場所でいうと岡場辺りかね
道場から岡場を通じて六甲山という
侵入ルートだと想定されているということでしょうか
六甲山に侵入するかどうか分かりません
ここは六甲山知りませんからね
やはり既に確認されているのはこういうエリアなんですよ
ですからこの辺から侵入してくる可能性が高いということで
もう少し空白ではありませんけれども
こういうエリアに置くということもあるかもしれません
この辺が理解的に注意しなければいけないエリアだろうと思います
もう一点だけすみません
罠に関しても同じような場所を重点的に設置するという方向で見ましょう
そうですね
経済学校の野崎学科の予報と申します
よろしくお願いします
罠につきましては
ちょっと場所が急斜面であったらなかなか仕掛けられないとか
条件があると思うんですけれども
やはりここで発見されたというところもありますので
この地域を十分的に強化していきたいというふうに考えています
他にございますでしょうか
産経新聞さん
産経新聞の神戸新聞さんの質問にかなるんですけれども
他側なんですが
一応県の許可がいるということで
申請ということなんですが
早ければいつぐらいに現場に設置できるといいますか
どれくらいのネットでいったんだ
許可を出すのが県ということになりますので
通常では1週間ぐらいなんですけれども
かなり協力していただけるというところなので
早ければすぐにでも出てくるのかなという形に思っておりますし
もう数日中に出てくる
これはちょっと優柔すぎね
1週間では
県は何してるんですか
やっぱりそれでは困ると思いますよ
早急にもう県に行くのが出てるわけですから
早急に県の調整書許可を得るようにしてもらわないといけない
と思います
ありがとうございます
他にご質問ございますでしょうか
読売新聞さん
読売新聞の村子さんいます
最初の話になったように
今回出没があったところから
近くに学校があるというところなんですけど
今のところは教育委員会の方では何か対策とか何か動きがあるという予定は今のところはないんですか
いや何もしてないというわけではなくて
当然その学校と連絡をして
少女学校幼稚園については当然その警戒
両を警戒している
それから陶芸校についての保護者への協力ということも当然の要因だろうと思います
ただ休校の措置をすぐ取ったというのは
やはりいろんな影響があるし
保護者に対する不安ということも出てきましたが
現時点においてはそこまでの措置を取る必要はないというふうに
教育委員会を判断したということだと思います
これまでの神戸市の方では
熊は出ないものじゃなくて出るということを想定して
これまでいろいろ準備されてきて
実際ここで出たんですけれども、改めてシーンの方に、こう出るわけないというわけじゃないんだよということで、改めてどういう思いを今、注意を呼びかけたいか、もう一言いただいていいですか。
思いということになりますと、やはり月間は出る可能性が高いというふうに、私も含めてこういうふうに考えておりまして、
2年前ですけれども、神戸に築沢沼が現れる日というコーラムが開いたんですよ。
これは本当の、現れてほしくないという思いを、願いを込めながら開いたんですけれども、
残念なことに現れてしまったということだと思います。
つまりこれ、想定外ではないということです。
神戸はこの六甲山系の後、山の恵みを私たちは受けていますけれども、山があるということは、こういう野生生物が現に存在をしていて、野生生物からも私たちは恵みを受けていますけれども、同時にリスクがある。
その最も典型的なものが月のワードナーですね。月のワードナーが神戸は、神戸市内にはいなかったわけですよね。
周りからすでに相当出没件数があると
あるいは確認されたものが
三田の三県、高田の三県
未確認の情報というのは
マシア市内でも、あるいは三田市内でも、三木市内でも
未確認の情報というのがあるので
やはり神戸に突き回るのが現れる可能性があるということは
やはり現に現れたわけですから
特に公務士のスタッフを中心にですね
山林に近いところあるいは山林に近いエリアに住んでおられる方には
意識を持っていただきたいということだと思います
同時に公務士は先ほどもありますように
かなりの監視体制をとっていますので
突然ですね
宇都宮の繁華街に突然
クマが合われる可能性が
100%低いなの
ああいうことが起きる
ですから候補者はこういう体制を
とっていますから
無用の心配
ということは
していただくことも
ないのではないか
私どもはさらに今回の
こういう情報
確認をもとに
緊張感をして
監視体制の強化と対応に当たっていきますので
冷静に対応して緊張感を持って冷静に対応していただくということを
市民の方にはお願いをしたいと思います
他にございますでしょうか
NHKさん
NHK西川ですよろしくお願いします
今回熊野県なんですけれども
もう1等のみの確認ということですが
他に例えば別の個体が出る可能性とかというのは
どのくらいあり得ると今分かっている範囲では
あるだろうと思います
どれくらいとやりますか
私に含めるとそれは誰も分からない
大事なことはしっかりこういうカメラ
リアルタイムで情報が入る
AIでクマかシカか他の動物が分かるようになっているんですが
それが確認されたら迅速に対応するということだと思います
それから少し細かい点なんですけれども
市として市内でクマが確認されたということは初めてという理解でよろしいですか
明確に確認されたのは初めてです
ただクマらしきものが現れたという情報はこれまでもありました
黒い物体黒い動物が大きな黒い動物が動いていたという話もありましたし
これから北区でも大きな動物の足跡があったという通報がありましたが
直ちに担当職員が現地に来ましたら
これはハクビシンの足跡だったということが確認されました
未確認の情報はこれまでもありました
明確に確認されたのは今回は初めてだと思います
ありがとうございます
最後に罠の話で権利強化が必要というか
先ほどもありましたけれども
あなたは市長としては県に対しては早く素早く対応していただくようなことをお願いしたいという理解がありました。
県の有害少女担当部局と工事の有害担当部局は非常に連携を密にしてスムーズに仕事が行われるというふうに思いますけど、
しかし現に今が出没しているのに罠をかけるのに、我々は一緒に罠を用意しているわけです。
それが県がなかなか許可を出してくれないために
不安な状態が続くと極めて起こる問題だと思いますから
そこは強く納税をしたいという担当部局で
しっかり行ってもらうことにしたりします
ありがとうございます
他にご質問ございますでしょうか
共同通信
地図でご説明いただいたと思うんですけれども
隣接地域を含めてこの赤丸で書かれている文章だと思うんですけれども
2024年に初めて確認されたということなんでしょうか周辺では
それはよくわかります
これは3だとなからずから見ました
神戸市にも参加地域がありますけれども
それでもクマが現れなかった事情というものは何かあったりするんですか
それはわかります
現れるか合われていないかはわからないようです
ただ現れたということをちゃんと監視をして確認するシステムです
こういう市はおそらく全国の中でも
最も唯一した監視システムを間違いなく持っている
それによって監視確認するものができているということですから
これとあとは目撃情報とかあるいはそれを目撃情報をもとにした現地調査によって
これまで対応してきておりますから
これまで明確な隙間が確認されたということはないと思います
今回初めてだということはこれはかなりの確率でいいものではないかという意味です
わかりましたありがとうございます
他にご質問ございますでしょうか
よろしいでしょうか
ご質問がないようでしたら
以上で本日の会見の方を終了したいと思います
ありがとうございます
よろしくお願いします
ご視聴ありがとうございました。